my guest tonight is a talented actress
who starred in Game of Thrones and Dark
Phoenix now you can see her in the new
kwibi TV series survive which debuts on
April 6th please welcome the lovely and
talented sophie turner Sophie how are
you I'm good thanks kind and how are you
I'm great you're staying safe you're
you're quarantined yeah very very safe
very very quarantined loving it I mean
obviously this is you know a lot of bad
news out there but you like this
business of staying home don't you yeah
I mean I'm an introvert I'm a homebody I
just like I if I could stay at home all
day I would so this is great for me I
leave the house like once a day anyway
to walk my dogs and then that's it so
nice yeah I mean I don't know how people
are I see how people are finding it
difficult but I I don't understand how
people are really struggling to practice
social distancing right we have to do is
stay at home and like get drunk at home
no wait a minute I've been listening to
talk turf ouchie on CNN and nowhere does
he ever say just get drunk at home yeah
but you know he's thinking it you know
he's doing the same thing yeah half the
time I see him on television he seems
tipsy yeah that face mom yeah
behind home facepalm yes do you like the
fact that I mean you've been on my show
many times you're always very
beautifully dressed this must be this is
a real change for you you look gorgeous
but you can kind of just wear anything
do you like this I love this this is
great isn't it like you don't have to
get dressed up I'm wearing my sweatpants
oh wow oh yeah I'm like I'm I'm business
on top policy on the Boston hey I'm
reading in the paper that couples are
having a hard time being quarantined
together
how are you enjoy getting along yeah I
had the divorce rates were up Joan I
it's actually kind of everything seems
to be working out in my favor here
because Joe's like he's a real social
butterfly so
I struggle to kind of lock him down and
haven't just spent time with me so it's
kind of it's like prison for him but
it's great for me like I'm sure it's not
prison for him but how does he pass the
time what does he do he's taken up like
her Instagram like DJ set he started
doing that DJing at home yeah he's doing
really really loudly while I read my
scripts he's DJing at home like the
other day yesterday or the day before he
was dead he did like an 80 set for a
good pot like two hours eighties music
for two hours mm-hmm yeah okay that
would be rough I mean there's some great
80s music and then there's other 80s
music I don't think I could hear
soft-sell over and over and over again I
know well you're lucky you know in this
house really okay well he's DJing what
is your role how do you support him
um I pull him his drinks I pull him his
alcohol I give him tequila shots he'll
like text me and be like what time is it
and then I'll reply from the kitchen
shot time and bring him some a shot
tequila
it's curious what time is shot time does
it have to be like after 5:00 it's fun
it's really fun and like I get to dress
him up according to what kind of the
theme is of the DJ set so 80s I dressed
him up and like some this like
windbreaker that was very colorful and
very 80s and I think the next one's
gonna be these the reggae music so I
don't know I don't know if I have the
right the right attire for that but I'll
see what I can do I can ship you over
some stuff I know that you have the
right stuff I have all the right dress
reggae all the time baby all day that's
my thing when when I'm at home you know
yeah do you find that do you think that
you dress more comfortably at home than
Joe does yeah definitely
because he's like I mean this is this is
something that I only kind of come to my
attention since this quarantine thing
but I saw him it was like a meme online
or someone some comment or something and
someone said like if you're wearing
denim pants at home like what does that
say about you drink denim during the
quarantine at home when no one can see
you and no one can see what does that
say about you as a person like you
that's like a bad yeah Joe does that Joe
well as denim trousers at home but no
one can see I'm I'm not I'm not wearing
denim trousers yeah who's dressed up
I've been days I know I I also I can
relate to Joe because I've been wearing
jeans a lot and sometimes I look and I
think why am I doing this well I do that
to your groin kind of well I'm Catholic
any punishment any punishment down in
that area that feels right to me maybe
we could let it fly
[Laughter]
I'm told that you have a special
background that you made just just for
me that you wanted to show me is that
right yeah I have a special background
just fee it's not I don't know if it'll
fit the screen
yeah oh my god I know what that is what
is that yes look at that that's when you
came on my show and you demonstrated a
slap for me that's right I slapped you
slap me and I remembered you were a
little worried before the show I knew
you were gonna slap me you were a little
worried about and I said the only way
this is gonna work is if you really go
for it yeah you were you were great
school I have to say
that's the hardest I've been hit in my
life I'm so sorry don't be sorry it was
great people loved it people loved it
online but I thought well I hope she
goes for it and then you went for it and
you are strong and you we are really
drunk on the show like you made me do I
think I did that could sound bad I
didn't make a date we did three shy
think three shots of tequila like on the
stage and I had to go and get on a
flight right off smashed through customs
it was awful
it's the best way to to get on a flight
it is with the good buzz I understand
you've been a little unhappy with people
that aren't social distancing especially
young people that that's been pissing
you off yeah it's been pissed I think
it's pissing everyone off who's you know
making like an effort to stay in and and
really try to slow the spread of the
virus I mean my eldest brother and my
sister-in-law they are doctors in the UK
and they just got transferred to the ICU
and it's so frustrating seeing these
people like going out and spring
breaking all over the place like in
Malibu it's packed right now and in
Miami I guess and it's just like I don't
understand how you can be you know that
selfish to put doctors lives at risks
who are gonna have to end up treating
you and then you know become vulnerable
to to the infection by treating you like
I think if we can all stay huh I mean
you're literally being asked to do
nothing you know I mean like that's it
should be fairly easy it's almost
because people can't see it you know and
if you can't see it I think there are
some people that think hey what are we
doing this is my beach time this is my
Spring Break yeah what's harshing my
mellow I want to get out there I don't
think anyone's saying harsh my mellow
but but anyway you are
I am I'm I'm 79 years old I got a chance
to start watching your show on kwibi and
your your show is the first show that
I've ever watched on kwibi survive and
it's beautiful it's really well done
it's it's fantastic oh thank you really
proud of this we're really proud of it I
mean I kind of just just getting around
to to watch it I haven't watched it all
yeah in fact I don't think they sent me
the last episode so I'm wondering what's
gonna happen you have been drinking a
lot actually that's not that's not not
true on on that movie we were shooting
in the Dolomites in Italy and towards
the end of the shoot he's just wading
through like three feet of snow got the
best and got the best of us so we ended
up we would just kind of go and and they
were like little cabins little stations
for the gondolas and so we would just go
there and drink mulled wine right coffee
cups all day I haven't seen this prep
but you fight wolves in episode of the
show was that I mean this is you've had
experience with wolves before I'm gay
were you working with the same wolves
well you're like oh hey guys how are you
how's it bad actually yeah we were
working with the people who provided the
wolves for Game of Thrones
oh really same people yeah the same the
same people so it was actually quite
horrible because you know in Game of
Thrones like the wolves are our pets are
like our soul mates kind of and and on
this I have to basically like fight a
wolf and try and kill the thing yeah and
so I found it to be quite symbolic
actually you know like gameis it just
ended so I was you know figuratively
killing the wolf and ending my career
yes killing the the that part of that
part is over now that
Martis over it was wonderful but now the
analogy is the wolf must die yes exactly
I just the idea of you being reunited
with a wolf that you had worked with
before and like smoking a cigarette like
Sophie we have a clip here from survived
which we're going to show right now this
is with your co-star our Corey Hawken is
that right yes Corey Wilkins you guys
are stuck on the edge of a cliff I think
in this clip yeah we're stuck on the
edge of the cliff and there's no other
way down but to jump
what's a jump yes another good metaphor
for many things let's take a look at
that clip now huh
[Music]
and we're back
are you what a great clip wasn't that a
great clip it was we'll add that later
I'm being honest with my audience we
didn't see the clip right now we didn't
see anything that was good acting on
your part you too we should do a no no
you're doing really well and you do not
want to do get me into the movies with
you you you're just stay away from me as
an actor look out for survive on kwibi
it's really good and this is the perfect
time to be watching something like this
great new show in 10-minute installments
and if not now when
exactly and you know what it is really
nice to talk to you talk to you I'm so
happy for all the good things that are
happening in your life and that you're
staying well and enjoying the quarantine
you too
I mean I hope you're enjoying the
quarantine but I love coming on your
show I love seeing you you're you're one
of my favorites okay we'll just say
don't say one opening I can't say
favorite though because I think that if
I ever go on another show they'll call
me out for I know those other people and
they're very very bitter yeah not like
me hey Sophie thank you so much be well
stay safe my best to Joe and enjoy enjoy
your 80s music marathon I'll try to and
if you need anything I'll pick it up for
you and drive over to where you are and
throw it through your window
thanks so much please do okay once they
say